you had a look of surprise on your face
even when this woman said well you know
Norm was supposed to be my guide through
Saturday life guide did anyone inform
you that you were her guide no no no
there was no such mentoring program in
Saturday Night Live was it oh no she
came in directly after me so I wouldn't
be her Mentor yeah I'm not going to
guide any lady through comedy that would
take me uh first of all I'd have to
figure out how a lady could do
comedy
you you've admitted that you're lazy I
think you've read six books in your life
I've read six six what kind of a woman
would be attracted to you do you
think well I have a lot of money
oh and there's this movie coming out yes
title undetermined at this point
chairman of the board oh all right do
something with that you freak
I I bet the board is spelled b o r e
d you know before I did the show I never
realized how much work it took to put on
a production like this check it out they
spent two months building all these
incredible sets they had to coordinate
14 live music acts and most of
impressive of all they they had to find
a seat filler for Jennifer Lopez she's
got a
now maybe you guys are right maybe she
doesn't have a gigantic ass I stand
corrected
well well I'll tell you it's nice to be
back on stage out here you know I don't
want to say my dressing room is small
but uh Tommy Lee just dropped by to
visit he shook hands with Carmen Electro
he blew out a
wall he's got a huge
anyway our next presenters are talented
young stars who became over night
Sensations with their brilliant debut
albums and if I can take this moment to
off for a little friendly advice kids
whatever you do when you put out your
second albums don't suck please welcome
T Bachman and Britney Spears it's time
for our next presenters and for a long
time there's been a rivalry between west
coast rappers and East Coast saxophone
players but tonight they have put their
differences aside to be here please
welcome Warren G and Ken
G well our next group has had a song on
the top of the Rock charts for 18 weeks
in fact they had four number one singles
off their debut album My Own Prison
that's more than Talent that's pure dumb
luck here the a
Creed well this is it the last award of
the
night that's right in about 5 minutes
everybody here is going to be at a big
party and in 5 minutes I'm going to uh
I'm going to collect my 20 $0000
paycheck and get my soothing back rub
from Dick
Clark the back rub was the deal breaker
and there's Charles Woodson how about
that I what a season he
[Applause]
had great man he became the first
defensive player to win the Heisman
Trophy and congratulations Charles that
is something that no one can ever take
away from you unless you kill your wife
and a waiter in which case
all bets are
option just a word of
advice okay Norman you're Canadian yes I
am so what do you think of this whole
presidential mess uh well I I hope that
uh uh the Democrats don't steal the
election from the uh the winner you know
but who
knows you like George Bush don't I love
George Bush man he's a good man decent
you know none of this
and he's you know he's not a a liar
crook murderer or anything like that so
it' be good to get the see I I don't I
think we should get the homicide out of
the White House and get like a a a fresh
start cuz we don't want any more
murderers I think we should just go on
to the next question who are the
murderers yeah oh Clinton he murdered a
guy yeah you know we're not allow you're
not allow to put out accusations without
a little too far it let's just let's
just go on to the next one
yeah this is not my week what can I tell
you oh it's not mine either and I'm
being very nice
okay be a good boy now Norm do you never
hear that no list we don't need to talk
about this and I don't want to hear it
and this is not the place to make those
accusations and you're supposed to be
funny let's get on exactly get with
there you go this is a live show for
nothing but you have been properly
chastised by Barbara so I'm not going
has the next question I thought it was a
matter of record shut up shut up look
let me do this okay I'll tell you what's
a matter of record you will not be
invited back if you don't shut up all
right
now and Veteran news Anchorman David
Brinkley apologized to Bill Clinton for
an election night commentary in which he
called the president quote boring and
uncreative admitted Brinkley there was
certainly nothing uncreative about the
way you moved Vince Foster's
body president's a murderer you didn't
know
that hey for the ninth consecutive year
Nick Jet Blue Air airlines rank first
for satisfaction among all North
American Airlines but you know what
ranked least in
satisfaction 9911 Airlines what a
terrible name for an airline it reminds
me of that
tragedy oh nice
911 I don't laugh at 911 I try to tell
him not to laugh I know I Walk Through
Blood and Bones in the streets of
Manhattan trying to find my brother
Jesus yeah he was in Northern
Canada thanks I'm nor McDonald and now
the fake news well it is finally
official murder is legal in the state of
California
and the pope came out with a book this
week which contains a series of essays
examining faith and morality in today's
secular world and the changing role of
the Catholic Church as it approaches the
21st century the book is entitled God
himself told me that OJ is
guilty in his book OJ Simpson says that
he would have taken a bullet or stood in
front of a train for Nicole
man I'm going to tell you that is some
bad luck when the one guy who would have
died for you kills you that's
[Applause]
prob well let's get to OJ OJ Simpson's
lawyers say they don't want the families
of Nicole Brown and Ronald Goldman in
the courtroom during the trial they're
afraid the presence of the family
members will just remind OJ of how much
more killing he still has to
do according to the National
Transportation safety board sleepy
truckers are responsible for 1,000
deaths a year in second place OJ Simpson
at two deaths a
year safer drivers men or women well
according to a new survey 55% of adults
feel that women are most responsible for
minor fender benders while 78% blame men
for most fatal crashes please note that
the percentage in these pie graphs do
not add up to 100% because the math was
done by a
woman for those of you hissing at that
joke it should be noted that that joke
was written by a woman so now you don't
know what the hell to do
[Applause]
then no I'm just kidding we don't hire
women
tell uh thank you very much H you're
very kind you know when the uh what's
that oh yeah I know no you're absolutely
right that is my name you know when the
people when the people here asked me to
do the show you know I got to say I I
felt kind of weird you know I I don't
know if you remember this but I used to
actually be on this show you know I used
to do the Weekend Update news routine
you remember that and uh
yeah that's where I did the make believe
news jokes you know that was me right so
then a year and a half ago right I had a
sort of a a disagreement with the
management at uh at the NBC uh I wanted
to keep my job
right and they felt the exact
opposite so so you see they like uh they
fired me because they said that I wasn't
funny you know now
now with most jobs I could have had a
hell of a lawsuit on my hands for that
but but see this is a comedy
show so they got me you know you know
want you know want but now this is a
weird part right it's only a year and a
half later and now they asked me to host
the
show so I wondered I go hey wait a
second here
hey I know how did I go in a year and a
half from being being not funny enough
to be even allowed in the
building to being so funny that I'm now
hosting the
show how did I suddenly get so damn
funny it was inexplicable to me because
a year and a half let's face there not
enough time for a dude to learn how to
be
funny then it occurred to me I haven't
gotten funnier the show has gotten
really
[Applause]
bad so yeah I'm funny compared to you
know well you'll see later
but okay so let's
recap the bad news is I'm still not
funny the good news is the show
blows all right folks we got a bad show
for you tonight Dr Dre Snoop Doggy Dog
and Eminem are here we'll be right back